[Applause]
he looks like alvin from the chipmunks
all right it's time once again for
great job there
joe so within hours of the taliban
season control of kabul the stories of
ghoulish behavior toward women erupt
they make andy cuomo look like andy
williams
turns out surprise they aren't an
enlightened bunch they're not only stuck
in the dark ages they prefer everyone
else joined them there so they have that
in common with the green new deal
but it may get worse their idea of
women's rights is letting her air out
her burka once a year
however we've been told by the press
this is a kinder gentler taliban so what
does that mean exactly they only
partially behead you
they only throw gays out of an
eight-story window not a 12-story one
did you see how one taliban leader freed
from gitmo by then president obama is
back on the job and i don't mean as a
tenured professor
we held on to him and then let him go we
probably fed him better than his fellow
fighters he's the only terrorist in the
group with type 2 diabetes
compared to the hell on earth they
created back home gitmo's a spa weekend
on our dime
all that's missing are the conjugal
visits from his favorite goat
it's not like the goat's gonna write
letters
and they don't get this in afghanistan
so you've seen this picture of hordes of
evacuating civilians packed into a cargo
plane you're staring at that in
disbelief how is that even possible
meanwhile spirit heiress say you know
we're getting some ideas here
so
here's an analogy
there's a pack of wolves outside your
door waiting for you to leave so they
can devour your grandmother maybe before
you leave you kill the wolves you don't
just go see you granny best of luck with
the wolves unless maybe she stiffed you
this year on that five dollars in your
birthday card
but this ain't armchair quarterbacking
i'm not tall enough to be a qb and
secondly what's an armchair
but given it was american blood and
treasure lost we need to hear the truth
here's one vet unleashing reality on a
soggy brian williams
he owned his decision he owned the fact
that as he put it the buck stops with
him
i hope he gets to hone their deaths too
i i don't i feel like i watched a
different speech than the rest of you
guys i was appalled
there was such a profound bold face lie
in that speech the idea that we plan for
every contingency
i have been personally trying to tell
this administration since it took office
i've been trying to tell our government
for years that this was coming we sent
them plan after plan on how to evacuate
these people
nobody listened to us
of course brian really did need to hear
that he's been in kabul this whole time
training the rebels
[Laughter]
after he killed bin laden
but there's still some in denial like
this witless water cannon
95 of the american people will agree
with everything he just said
95 of the press covering this white
house will disagree
and for an american president
to finally be completely aligned with
such an overwhelming majority of what
the american people think about
afghanistan is probably a tremendous
relief to the american people
talk about brain dead
they should change change the name of
her show from deadline to flatline
you know i'm not bashing the decision to
leave it's how the atrocious exit
negated so much sacrifice this is truly
a man-made disaster in biden's
speech yesterday he defiantly defended
his botched exit as if we were critical
of leaving but we weren't we were
critical of his incompetence in carrying
it out timing is everything in life joe
if anybody should know that it's a man
who probably starts his day with
fibricon and a pot of black coffee
people over 60 get that
my core audience
imagine
imagine if captain sully had bailed and
let his plane crash into the hudson
technically it's still a water landing
but only one gets you played by tom
hanks
but even if i wanted to defend biden i
can't i mean i do have a nagging
question in joe's defense if 20 years
made no difference on the exit you think
taking another few months would make any
difference
but still it's on biden remember as
president he said that the number one
threat to america wasn't the taliban
al-qaeda or isis it's millions of white
voters so screw him he didn't see the
taliban resurgence because he was too
busy indulging fabricated adversaries in
between photo ops of him licking ice
cream cones
and as for the democrats it's par for
the course in afghanistan just as on the
border or in law enforcement the dems
always embrace what undermines order
they're like a hooker deciding what bra
to wear they choose what comes apart the
fastest
[Laughter]
i got that from charlie
as for those
documenting the horrors of the taliban
ask yourself this would they have
supported an all-out fast annihilation
of taliban in a world where every
attempt to fight radical terror was met
with cries of islamophobia you have been
called a monster or worse a trump
supporter to suggest such a thing
taliban leaders were in the president's
palace one missile would have ended that
photo op
but how would the chattering classes
take to that sorry that swift brutal
action should be reserved only for the
insurrectionists at the capitol
over here our f'd up media focused on
plastic straws mean tweets racist
halloween costumes misgendering refusing
a vaccine or appropriating another
ethnic group's food in the school
cafeteria and of course social media
galvanized mobs to cancel people for bad
jokes and bad memes an entire news
network smeared the police nightly and
chose to inflame racial tension for
ratings for years our priorities as a
nation were deliberately undermined even
as our troops toiled the war became less
than background noise we spent years
letting our attention to afghanistan
grow flabby to paraphrase harry chapin
the war learned to walk while i was away
hell the war is now old enough to drink
and too old for anthony weiner to date
and in all that time we still hadn't
prepared for this moment that's amazing
imagine you got 20 years to plan on your
exit and it's this bad
what were our leaders doing
too busy destroying this country i guess
very serious welcome tonight's guests
he's so brave the national anthem stands
when he plays former navy seal rob
o'neal
he's got the views of a senior
republican strategist and the looks of a
high school junior
townhall.com political editor guy benson
he's been a guest more often than hunter
biden on a crack pipe fox news
contributor and washington's opinion
editor charlie hurt
and she's like a line of coke
thin white and clings to your credit
card
fox news contributor cat tim
so obviously we're talking about
afghanistan i want to go to the person
who knows the most about this who killed
bin laden cat
a lot of people don't know i know i know
the way i you know the way that you hid
this so well and let rob take all the
credit yeah thank you for that by the
way
yes i guess i should you're probably
seething right now let me ask you who
are you mad at you know what i i was mad
at first then i was sad and now i just
feel gross yeah because uh that's ring
on a friday night
yeah so there we are but i i mean
a prime example of of where the
country's gone i don't know if you know
this i've been banned from an airline
for not wearing a mask i saw 800 people
on a mat on a plane yesterday not one
has been banned yeah from the country
and i can't get you know i'm not gonna
i'll make up a name we'll call it delta
airlines but like i can't even get back
on that you know how ironic it's just
delta airlines
delta variant 20 years after 9 11 i'm
the one on a no-fly list
i'm just asking am i crazy
something tells me though that you can
get a little you can get a little wild
out of here here's the here's the
problem
you see the problem the problem is
people always say to me you kill bin
laden so it must be nice never paying
for a drink again right i'm like yeah
it's nice until this guy in the airport
buys me a drink and then he wants it
all 15 guys had a shot and i've had 15
shots yeah that's how you get banned
it's better this way that you got shot
than the way bin laden did yeah yeah
well i he took three i took 15.
the jokes are just riding themselves yes
there's a joke about a bowling ball in
bin laden's head but you know why go
there
especially after you've dropped the goat
one yes exactly but you know what there
is footage of that
of the goat once i have it back in my
apartment i don't like unsubscribe or
later unsubscribe so um okay is it all
joe biden's fault 100 okay if there is
any silver lining in any of this
it is that there is nobody in washington
who deserves to own
100
of this catastrophe more than joe biden
and it's not
it's not a three-day catastrophe and
it's not even a 20-year
catastrophe it's a 50-year catastrophe
this guy has been the the the smartest
person when it comes to foreign policy
the smartest person in washington
for decades right it's why he was vice
president he was vice president over
operations in afghanistan longer than
dick cheney was
and he he has been the genius in
washington when it comes to foreign
policy and when it comes to coming up
with uh ideas like this uh
more than anybody else and it's it's a
reminder that washington is the only
place on earth where you can be this
dumb and this bad and have this much
failure and face no consequence
you're so right and i'm trying to
remember who i had this conversation
with but they but guy we always assume
that when there's important things going
on the people involved doing the
important things are somehow better than
us smarter than us but when you end up
in that arena you find out they're just
as dumb as the people you went to high
school with
or you're currently going to high school
with
i'm in college
[Laughter]
or worse right so this is the thing not
only are they institutionally stupid and
they all sort of feed off of each other
and the bubble gets very very thick
what is very frustrating to watch and
experience is their contempt for us
thinking that we
are equally stupid or even dumber so we
watched the president yesterday we
watched the national security adviser
today
literally tell us we planned for all
contingencies yeah while the country is
going
absolutely to hell people are clinging
onto airplanes and plunging to their
death they are that afraid of the
terrorist organization that took over in
four days which they themselves told us
wasn't possible last month
and then they say oh don't worry we had
all the contingencies covered it's like
my first job was babysitting the
neighbors
if my neighbors came home from their
date night the house is on fire the dog
is dead the kids are missing i'm like
well i plan for all contingency right i
wouldn't i wouldn't want to be
congratulated for it but that was the
tone that biden took
right congratulations to me you're
welcome america i have done this and it
was just head spinning i bet you were a
good babysitter i was very responsible
yeah i could tell you do you just look
so responsible if you're watching girls
they probably had a crush on you didn't
they i would really die
i would read the wall street journal
at night and drink uh warm milk yes of
course you
would then you'd like defecate in a
closet
because you're a sick little man wow
yeah i went to a dark place that went
really sideways yes i know sometimes it
happens with me i don't know what's
wrong with me guy cat i don't know
what's going on right now what is your
take on this we we've you are um i would
say half a veteran but probably won't
say that yeah but uh you are married
married
in afghanistan yes every day you hear
how bad this was he is so upset
and it's so pervasive and i did a lot of
research today looking at all the things
that all these generals were saying for
20 years they're all saying oh this is
going great this is going great all this
progress all this progress all this
progress and if you look at you know
washington post 2019 obtained documents
they knew that wasn't true right and
what i don't understand is how so many
of these same people are still being you
know lauded as foreign policy experts
like david petraeus everyone's know what
does he think the only thing he's an
expert on is
and that wrong that often or lie that
often i'd be fired and when i'm bad at
my job nobody dies it's disgusting every
veteran i know is so upset about it and
i'm upset watching them be upset and i'm
upset for them and
by the way kat if you were ever a super
failure at your job you could just go
work at the view hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else